the Joe Rogan experience we were talking
earlier about probiotics dudu is there a
benefit of probiotics once you've taken
antibiotics to Riefler --is-- your gut
flora you know that's where the studies
really at this point have demonstrated
that it's very temporary in other words
if you're taking probiotics you can get
a boost initially but it doesn't sustain
yourself over time and then the natural
flora comes back I mean the gut microbes
will come back as as they've been
reduced but what I'm saying is is it
beneficial to people if they do take a
probiotic after antibiotics because
antibiotics do have a devastating effect
on your floor yeah
kills the bad stuff but it also kills a
lot of the good stuff right yeah so is
it beneficial for people once they have
taken an antibiotic to take probiotics
to sort of reflect an pereira yeah and
that's what i'm saying is that it
doesn't the data don't support that it
states in other words you get a
short-term boost material but they don't
stay around what if you just keep taking
it even then they they just don't stay
around your normal gut flora will come
back and take over so the probiotics and
of themselves are not giving you that
long-term busie so you don't think
there's any benefit to having even even
a short-term boost well you know it's
again I surely I'm not going to profess
to be the expert on probiotics right
tell you that the data we have doesn't
show that they have a big boost and and
that they actually help you long term or
short term meaning that it makes any
difference now there's one exception to
that where I would say and this is a
very different thing than probiotics but
we actually have a disease called
Clostridium difficile which is a bad
bacteria that happens when you've taken
away too many antibiotics and and it's
colonizers your gut because you don't
have competing organisms there and then
you can die from this there are
treatments for that called actually
fecal transplants yeah I've heard of
that and that's where actually there you
take it little capsules but it's
actually drinking poop when purified
purified bugs from the poop you're right
but you take that and that's that's that
kind of is what you're talking about
that does have a real been if
and there is clear evidence that if you
take those those fecal transplants as
opposed to just probiotics or such that
that can have a major positive impact on
your recovery from things like colostrum
difficile infection and so more and more
institutions now actually are doing
fecal transplants which you've never
thought that that would be one thing you
do one day but those have had this
problem their their life saving there
maybe we should change the name that
would although on the other hand you
don't forget it if you're right yeah you
don't forget if it's a fecal transplant
but that's what's gonna be yeah nerve
wracking to people yeah yeah you know
once you're that sick boy it feels good
to take it it does you know have you
done it I've never done it have you ever
had a problem where I've had to but but
for the Ives know people who have been
desperately sick who have taken them and
have really done much better much much
better
[Applause]